Good Morning Hank, it's Thursday.
Special Suprise Bonus Video. So, um, I have written a book.
That feels good to say. Also a little terrifying.
It's called Turtles All the Way Down. It comes out on October 10th and it is available for preorder now.
Link in the Doobly-Doo below.
My previous book, The Fault in our Stars, came out more than five and a half years ago,
so this book has definitely been a long and winding road,
but I am /so/ excited to share it with you.
I don't want to say to much about the plot of the book
but it's a story about a young woman who's trying to solve a mystery
while also trying to live with mental illness.
And in that sense, while it is definitely a made-up story,
it's also kind of a personal one
because as most of you know, I have a mental illness
that, at times, has taken over my life.
So ok! I think that's all the relevant information for right now:
title, publication date, available for preorder,
one sentence of extremely vague introduction!
I'm so happy to be finished with the book that I'm proud of.
I really hope you like it!
Also, I just wanna say a quick word of thanks --
A lot of people have been /really/ patient with me
and kind over the last five and a half years,
especially my family, so...thank you!
I have often worried that I would never publish another book,
and without their support, I wouldn't be.
Now, I know many of you will have questions.
Please leave them in comments below
and I will try to answer some in next Tuesday's video
Which, by the way, is going to be an unboxing video because I hear those are popular on YouTube.
Hank, I will see you tomorrow.
That's another thing I haven't gotten to say for a while.